there is a stunning new report
out of politico that officials in palm
beach florida
are actively contingency planning for a
possible
indictment of former president donald
trump by manhattan
district attorney sy vance jr which
could happen
while donald trump is at his florida
club mar-a-lago
that this is even something being gamed
out
by palm beach officials is stunning the
sources here
are two high-ranking county officials
from palm beach involved in these
planning sessions
the real legal question is that of
extradition from florida to new york
in the event of a new york indictment of
trump now what's ironic or tragic or
i don't know what to call it is that
because of an obscure florida statute
about interstate extradition
it would basically come down to the
florida governor who currently
is the pro-trump republican governor ron
desantis who could ultimately decide to
intervene
and do an investigation of his own to
determine
whether the indicted person should be
extradited to another state
joe abruzzo clerk of the circuit court
of palm beach county says quote
the statute leaves room for
interpretation that the governor has the
power to order a review
and potentially not comply with the
extradition notice
now on the other hand trump is currently
moving from mar-a-lago in florida to his
bedminster new jersey estate for the
summer
if a new york city indictment came down
with trump in jersey
it's a different ball game there's also
a statute there allowing the governor to
intervene
but the governor in new jersey is
democrat phil murphy
not a trump sycophant brown-noser would
likely just not get involved at all
and if trump were in new jersey at the
time of the indictment trump likely
would be extradited to new york so
there's multiple layers here to consider
first of all imagine a former president
getting indicted period would be one of
the biggest
news stories in american political
history period second
imagine if former president trump is
indicted and he's in florida
and florida governor ron desantis
refuses to extradite trump
consider what that would mean in terms
of the legal insanity of a governor
protecting a former president from
extradition
on an indictment and that trump would
essentially become a fugitive
in his own country at least to his
native new york
and likely wouldn't be able to travel to
new york on the risk of arrest
now i think that while desantis would
plot plausibly intervene there are
plenty of republican officials who love
the idea of trump
and an indictment as a way to finally
get trump out of the way
and try to commandeer trump's very
constituents for themselves
these would be the republicans who
publicly still stand by trump
but probably privately think he's an
idiot and bad for the republican party
could ron desantis even try to intervene
but in exchange for something imagine
desantis going to trump and saying
i'll intervene to stop the extradition
but then you owe me
and what i want is for you not to run in
2024
and to endorse me for president in 2024.
i don't know but trump being stuck in
florida without being able to leave
is already pretty rich having to endorse
the guy that
saves him would be a just delightful
possibility now do i think any of this
will happen
very unlikely i know we've all thought
about that perp walk
that potential moment where donald trump
is handcuffed and walked in front of the
cameras but that is so
far from a real possibility even if
trump were indicted he wouldn't be
perp-walked it would all be very quiet
and quite frankly
i think it's all very far-fetched but
the fact
that it's potentially real enough that
officials around the country are
thinking about
if trump is indicted how do we handle it
that's already historic
and it is absolutely stunning that it's
the discussion
monday memorial day we are doing a
one-day membership special
okay this is what we call a single day
membership
bomb if you want to get in on a
membership
including all of the great benefits as
well as the world's famous award-winning
bonus show
monday memorial day is a beautiful day
to do it uh just get on my newsletter go
to davidpakman.com
upper right of the website you type in
your email address you get on my
newsletter
monday memorial day you'll get an email
telling you exactly
how to take advantage of this special
quick break back after this
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation
because they're either dry or boring or
don't taste that good or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor
monk pack is completely different
because monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture and yet
they have only 140 calories
one gram of sugar and only two to three
net carbs perfect
for the low sugar or keto diet they come
in
fantastic flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
blueberry almond vanilla and the new
flavor
peanut butter i've been a fan for a long
time i always have them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i do
you get all your money back they also
now have a subscription feature which i
love it'll save you 10 percent on every
order
and it ships automatically you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video